[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHAELA KEPLINGER-MITTERLEHNER:
Nowadays, everyone
is searching for
information online.
Raiffeisen is the largest
banking group in Austria,
so we need to provide our
customers with accurate
information quickly.
WALTER MOESENBACHER:
Our internal data
was poorly managed.
And so we had a bad
online presence,
especially in Google Maps.
People couldn't find the right
addresses of our branches,
the right phone numbers.
We used Google Maps APIs to
help us consolidate and optimize
our online information.
Because our data was
up-to-date, customers
found what they were looking
for quickly and easily.
We see the actual
results immediately.
Our final optimization was 20%
with 60% increased conversion
in the first year.
MICHAELA KEPLINGER-MITTERLEHNER:
With the help of Google Maps
APIs, we are able to
offer our customers a much
better online experience.
[MUSIC PLAYING]